hello everyone it might seem strange to
you that I'm uploading a video from the
Olympia this early but as this is the
last round of the Olympiad the round has
started some exactly four hours before
every other round so one game already
finished and it this game could might
could even be the game that decides the
fate of the entire 2018 but to me chess
olympiad everyone was checking out the
first boards Khurana very quickly drew
his game against Dingley rim but I was
very impressed by that game being really
put put up and put on some early
pressure and the Khurana really had to
defend properly but that game soon ended
in a draw dude I made a very nice draw
against Viswanathan Anand kurakin drew
on board won against France against
against Maxime for Sherlock Rob and so
we have this game on board too between
Russia and France its young upon yashi
vs. Etienne back row and it's a quite
quite an interesting game so let's just
check it out as I'm eager to see how
things will turn out in the Olympiad so
nipple goes Knight to f3 he goes for the
reti opening with a v5e 392 f6 c4 e6 and
this is one of the rare cases where we
do not transpose into the Queens gambit
declined rather Knight to c3 and okay we
have Bishop to e7 be three we have
castles Bishop to b2 and I see
developing move c5c capture son d5
Knight captures on d5 and here this
position was already played at once in
the st. Louis blitz tournament where my
Medea of defeated Worsley so with Queen
to be won but here we have a different
idea and Ipomoea she but prepares h4 and
in this line he will in fact not even
castle
we have b6 Queen to be won now you have
to develop the Queen some way we have h6
and now G 4 so already starting a nice
King side attack and move 10 Bishop to
b7
aligning the bishop which this night as
the Queen is no longer guarding it but
also with the rook so you do have to be
hit careful here
th-three getting rid of both threats at
once nights to be seven are getting the
other night into the game as well and
now g5 so already you can see that black
is definitely feeling the pressure here
h5 of course you don't want to play
something like H captures on g5 and the
given fo a nice open h-line here white
would already be threatening checkmate
that's why Queen B one is such a
powerful attacking move and of course g6
loses immediately tonight captures here
you cannot recapture because then rocket
jet will be checkmate to do to the
bishop guarding it from me - so after g5
h5 not allowing the H file to open and
now Bishop to d3 and here we have
Knights to be for a very nice move
hoping to get rid of an epilogue
LightSquared bishop first nipple gives a
check here rush up to h7 check came to
h8 and now he offers a trade of light
square bishop and while you can't do
this back roads the light square bishop
is also a very strong piece so for the
moment he he declines the exchange and
offers a trade of knights but we have
nice to e2 here as the h5 pawn is pretty
advanced nepo is hoping for some knife
to g3 to h5 action and here the critical
moment of the game you could still
defend this position with black after
Bishop to d6 simply not allowing the
knight to come to g3 but again after
night comes here Bishop captures rook
captures and the white is still better
but at least the game continues but
white still has immense pressure against
the black king but back road play f5
here and now this it's it's simply
winning for white and Napo finds a very
nice reputation of f5 he plays G captors
on f6 we have Knight 7 captures on f6
and now Knight to g5 now you can see
that the queen is still occurring that
h7 squared the Knight is guarding h7 so
if you could get rid of the bishop
engine tonight white will be able to
deliver checkmate also Knight 36 is a
threat forking the Queen and the rook so
if you play something like Queen to d6
the guard here
it doesn't work because the two bishops
are too strong you will simply eliminate
the defender of the h7 square with
Bishop captures on d5
now you can't capture with the night the
night has to keep an eye on this square
but after it captured the other Bishop
eliminates the other night which is the
defender of the h7 square and now Queen
to h7 is imminent so after Knight to g5
we have night capture sunny for
eliminating this bishop queen capture
sunny for my nipple and now Bishop
captures and g5 now queen h7 is no
longer a possibility but now H captures
ng5 and now the rook will be able to
capture here you cannot block this with
g6 queen will simply capture or even
better yet the point is pinned
silly me so not not even a possibility
and the move like Queen captures on g5
to prevent the rook from capturing here
will be met with rook to g3 now the rook
and Bishop are eyeing the g7 pawn Queen
has to move and now the simple Queen
captures on f5 rook captures and rogue
captures here any move white mix will be
a very nasty discovery so the bishop is
hanging efore is a terrible threat a
winning position for white so Etienne
tried Knight to f4 here opening up a
discovered attack against Naples Queen
also attacking the rook here so Queen
captures some b7 and now comes Knights
to d3 check King moves and now comes
Knight captures on b2 so eliminating a
very powerful attacking piece but it
doesn't matter nepalese rook captures on
h5 would have King to g8 and now comes a
move that wins the game in great style
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea I'll give
you a couple of seconds to decide
whether we want to do it or not for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just finished a
game in great style and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show if you
found Queen to e4 with the threat of
Queen to h7 that that will do but on the
other hand if you found g6 this is even
fancier this is what Napoleon in the
game and it was in this position that at
the end back-row decided to resign the
game the thing is there's nothing to do
here for example let's make
let's try and make a silly move with
with black let's try something like Ruby
eight what's the threat here the threat
is the very simple rook to HH check
allowing the Queen to come into the
attack with tempo King has the capture
only move as the point is guarding the
f7 square Queen a1 check King has to
move or you can waste a move with the
Queen but that's pretty pointless and
queen to h7 will be checkmate
so after this g6 move pretty much any
move you make will be will be met with a
rope to h8 check and then it is all over
so that's pretty much it I do hope you
enjoyed it now I'm gonna get back to
watching the Olympiad as the things are
getting very intense and Nakamura has a
huge task in front of him if the United
States wish to have a chance at first
place then Nakamura has to really create
wonders in that end game he's playing so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Brian
Carey ygm Carmen Maris Lauren's button
and Ronald Petit for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here think all for
watching and I'll see you very soon
most likely with another nice game from
the Olympiad see you soon